in the world of Demon Slayer there are
three legendary abilities that every
Slayer strives to unlock and even among
the strongest tour members throughout
history only a handful of characters
were able to unlock all three these
eight characters possess immeasurable
strength and power and can be rightfully
referred to as Demon Slayer gods and
today we'll be covering all of them
starting with the mysterious father of
our protagonist tanjaro comedo it may
seem weird at first the tantro's dad has
made it on the list but what if I tell
you that he possesses the incredibly
powerful ability that only a few other
demon Slayers have the transparent world
most of you probably don't remember but
we've seen this flashback in chapter 151
when he and Tantra went into the woods
there they encountered a giant bear and
Tundra was able to defeat it in the
blink of an eye using the transparent
world he was also the first character in
the series we've seen performing kagura
dance which we later Learned was closely
linked to the legendary Sunbury due to
very limited information about him it's
unknown if he could use this ability
offensively as Tundra does in the anime
or if he only ever used it during kakura
ritual another interesting thing is that
he is one of the only three characters
in the whole series naturally born with
the Demon Slayer Mark although judging
by the looks of it it seems that he
never fully awakened it now since Tonto
never unlocked the ability to turn his
weapon bright red you are probably
wondering why is he even on this list
well despite not having that specific
ability he had one that was even rarer
the selfless State this ability allowed
him to completely conceal his fighting
Spirit making it impossible for
opponents to sense him even though
Tantra never chose to become a Demon
Slayer his outstanding abilities and
potential definitely make him the
character worthy of this list alright
let's continue the list with the guy who
actually became a Demon Slayer the Miss
toshira muichiro tokito luigiro is a
child prodigy and one of his most
impressive Feats is becoming a hashira
with only two months of Demon Slayer
training although he is was only 14
years old he was skilled enough to
develop his own technique called
obscuring clouds which was powerful
enough to take down even the upper Moon
demons like he wasn't already strong
enough during his battle against
kokushibo his strength grew even further
eventually unlocking both transparent
world and bright red weapon although
these new abilities didn't allow him to
defeat kokoshibu by himself they played
a crucial role in finally stopping the
upper Moon one demon another important
thing to mention is that muichuro is the
descendant of sugikuni bloodline meaning
that both michikatsu and yorichi are his
distant relatives this most likely
explains his incredible natural talent
for demon slaying and the capacity to
unlock all of the legendary techniques
there are still six incredibly strong
characters left to cover and the next
one is obanai iguro the serpent hashira
although we didn't witness obanai fight
very often in the story it's undeniable
that he is one of the strongest hashira
members in the series his fighting style
is called serpent breathing and it
allows him to use snake-like movements
to quickly slash his opponents these
snakes can also be used to keep the
Subscribe button steady so open eye can
easily click it whenever he feels like
it go ahead try it while it's still here
anyway we've mostly witnessed his
abilities in his battle against muzon
where he managed to hold his ground
against the demon king for some time and
continue fighting even after being
completely blinded his physical strength
is also on another level as he managed
to turn his nature and sword bright red
through sheer grip strength alone while
most of the other hashira needed to do
it in some other way additionally obanai
was one of the first to shiris to figure
out how to use the transparent World
despite having no prior knowledge about
it although he eventually succumbed to
his injuries during the final battle he
played a major role in stopping muzon by
continuously getting back up and
fighting and as such deserves sixth
place on this list
the stone hashira the stone hashira
gilme is without a doubt the strongest
warrior in the current pillar generation
same as muichiro we discussed earlier he
also achieved the hashira's status in
only two months without any prior combat
experience due to his versatile fighting
style he doesn't use a regular nichiren
sword to fight instead he uses a mace
and an ax chain together which allows
him to perform a variety of defensive
and offensive techniques the most
interesting thing about yomei is that he
is actually blind which means that he
fights only relying on sound however
even with this major drawback he seems
to be more than capable of battling any
opponent that comes his way including
upper Moon 1 and even the Demon King
himself kokoshibo even stated that
yomey's physical abilities had been
trained to their absolute Peak and that
he didn't encounter a warrior as strong
as him for over 300 years same as other
characters on this list he awakened all
three of the legendary demon slaying
abilities and even helped others in
Awakening them too all in all yomey is
on a whole other level compared to all
the characters we covered so far but can
you imagine that there are still four
characters even more powerful than him
Ashira is from the sengoku era although
these characters were never properly
introduced and have only appeared in a
few manga panels it's certain that these
were some of the strongest demon Slayers
to ever live they were the first
generation of demon Slayers to learn
breathing Styles and they've learned
them from none other than yorichi
sukikuni himself these legendary demon
Slayers lived around 500 years ago and
since kokushibu said that yomei is the
strongest one in the last 300 years it
means that these hishiras were even more
powerful than him each of them also
easily awakened a Demon Slayer Mark and
survived their full lifespan of 25 years
although it was never mentioned if they
also had other abilities like
transparent world and bright red weapon
based on their strength they probably
did despite not having any information
about their battles and achievements I
think we can all agree that these
legendary Warriors deserve their spot on
this list moving on from characters we
don't know anything about to the one we
followed throughout the entire series
the child of brightness tanjaro comedo
although it's not unusual for a
protagonist to get increasingly more
powerful throughout the story Tundra's
Evolution was just perfect even before
becoming a Demon Slayer he was unusually
strong and had a really good fighting
intuition soon after his family was
killed by a demon he met sakonji and
learned the water breathing technique
from this point on he quickly started to
get more and more powerful defeating
increasingly strong demons like hand
demon gilgai mui and even lower Moon one
enmu however this was only the beginning
of his journey as soon after in the
entertainment District he unlocked the
first legendary Demon Slayer power the
Demon Slayer Mark with it he immediately
became powerful enough to defeat the
upper Moon demon a feat that hadn't been
achieved in over 100 years during his
battle against upper Moon 4 hon Tengu
with his sister's help tantro managed to
awaken another legendary ability the
bright red weapon this ability seemingly
allowed him to nullify the Regeneration
of demons he cut thus killing them even
if they attempted to regrow their head
another important thing to mention here
is that tantro awakened both of these
abilities before any other hashira did
further showcasing his natural talent
and potential to solidify himself as one
of the Demon Slayer gods in the final
Arc of the story Tundra managed to
awaken both the transparent world and
selfless State putting him miles ahead
of any other current hashira and even
allowing him to defeat upper Moon 3
akaza despite unlocking pretty much
every single ability a Demon Slayer can
and mastering the legendary Sun
breathing there are still two demon
Slayers who are even more powerful than
him and one of them is none other than
upper Moon one himself
is a legendary Demon Slayer who lived
during the sengoku era and who would
later be known as kokushiba the
strongest demon moon ever second only to
muzon while he was still a human
michikatsu was said to be on a
completely different level compared to
other demon Slayers in his era and had
developed his own breathing style called
Moon breathing which no other human
throughout history had ever mastered due
to jealousy and envy towards his brother
michikatsu eventually decided to join
hands with muzon and become his
right-hand man in order to gain more
power throughout his long life as a
demon kukushibo mastered his breathing
style developing 16 forms in total and
using them alongside his blood demon art
to neutralize any opponent that came his
way his true strength could be seen in
the final story arc when he engaged
muichiro here although muichiro had his
Mark activated kokoshipo managed to
effortlessly avoid all of his attacks
and defeat him in seconds even after two
more hashiras came to fight him he was
still busy simply stronger than them and
easily kept up with their attacks in the
end it took three marked ashiras along
with genya to finally bring him down
even though it was never officially
confirmed that michikatsu had the
ability to turn his sword right red I
think that based on his strength it's
pretty obvious that he did therefore he
deserves second spot on the list yorichi
sugikuni the man who defeated muzon
yorichi is by far the strongest Demon
Slayer in the entire story and the man
who invented the first ever breathing
style Sun breathing he is also the only
character in the series born with both a
Demon Slayer Mark and the potential to
freely use the transparent World ability
even as a child hirishi displayed an
unbelievable talent for swordsmanship
effortlessly defeating a master Samurai
without ever wielding a sword before
later in his life he developed the first
ever breathing style which aims to mimic
the Sun and deal irreversible damage to
Demons in his prime yorichi was
unmatched by humans and demons alike and
was the first person ever to break the
curse of the Demon Slayer Mark and live
Beyond 25 years of age at some point
when he was still a member of the corps
yorichi encountered muzan and in a short
battle that ensued he easily overpowered
him with even the Demon King being
unable to process what happened
yorichi's unparalleled strength left a
deep impression on muzon and from then
on he lived in constant fear of yorichi
and anyone else who uses Sun breathing
technique he even went as far as to say
that in this world filled with demons
yorichi was the biggest monster despite
muzan's incredible regenerative
abilities the wounds dirichi inflicted
on him that day were never fully healed
not even 500 years later it goes without
saying that yorichi possessed all of the
legendary Demon Slayer abilities and
obviously deserves the first place on
this list click on this video where we
explained what would happen if muzon
turned hirichi into a demon